chez un brur j'ai trouvé pour trois fois
rien P d'un kil de vieux disque
américain comme jitais le marchand s'est
s'approcher sur un vieux P il a posé le
premier il m'a dit je l' garantis ils
sont des PO du bon du S moi j'aime la
musique mais pas les antiquités j'allais
m'en aller quand un air
m'aroché je STI Souain pourM dans mes
pieds sans permission mes doigts ont
claqué ça Balan auend du
swingwing j'ai compris pourquoi mon
père j'ai compris
pourquoi
préou d'avoir 20 ans au bons du et de
dis en disque de chansons en musique
commerist col je découvra
[Musique]
l'amé
gar ça ban au bons du
swingwing j'ai compris pourquoi mon
père j'ai compris pourquoi ma
mère par
de les
paroir 20
[Musique]
answing
j'ai pris tous les dis acheté le Bonom
depuis chaque soir je me donne des con
rtros je joue des drames sur des gons à
[Musique]
Cha j'ai l'impression quelques heures
durant d'avoir 20 ans au bonour du swing
venez dans avec moi venez rêver avecmi
venez danser avec moi venez rêver
avalez-mi j'ai l'impression qu he du
d'avir 20 ans au monant du swing V
danser av-moi venez m'aider avec moi
venez danser i avec moi venez m'aider
venez avec
moi venez danser avec moi venez rêver
avec moi comme au bon viux
[Musique]
dans